prüfung tag und goethe stadt deutsch 1
das komplette vokabular mit dialogen
lektion 6
51 wörter
los geht's
wehen
oben
das appartement die appartements
der stock
über
ich habe
diese jungen leute schon einmal gesehen
ich habe diese jungen leute schon einmal
gesehen
wir wohnen oben
wir haben ein appartement gemietet
unsere wohnung liegt im zweiten stock
im dritten stock über der familie meyer
wohnen im dritten stock über der familie
meyer
heißen
die ehefrau die ehefrauen der
ehemann
die ehemänner
der sohn
die söhne
ich heiße charlotte meier
das ist mein ehemann klaus
das ist hector unser sohn
der partner die partner
die partnerin
die partnerinnen der
student die studenten
die studentin
die studentinnen
wie heißt ihr
meine partnerin heißt veronika
eine partnerin heißt veronika
ich heiße david
ich bin studentin
studieren
das studium
umziehen
ich studiere jura in basel
das studium beginnt im oktober
nächsten monat ziehen wir um
die uhr
der schluss
abholen muss
das wiedersehen
oh je es ist vier uhr
[Musik]
wir müssen jetzt schluss machen
wir müssen noch unseren freund abholen
also tschüss
auf wiedersehen
junge leute sagen meistens tschüss und
nicht auf wiedersehen
junge leute sagen meistens schuss und
gut
der morgen
der vormittag
der mittag
der nachmittag
der a
die nacht
gehen
guten morgen
ja wie geht's
wie gehen
es gibt so
treffen
bitten
der flughafen
das auto
die autos
ist das deine
ja heute abend fliege ich nach berlin
heute abend fliege ich nach berlin
es ist gut klaus dass ich dich getroffen
habe
darf ich dich um etwas bitten
kannst du mich zum flughafen bringen
kennst du mich zum flughafen bringen
mein auto ist kaputt
abfliegen
der abflug
7 uhr 15
13 uhr 17
wann fliegst du ab
der abflug ist um 20 uhr 20
okay das kann ich tun
die bitte die bitten
benutzen
schwer
leicht
ich habe noch eine bitte
aufzüge bitte nicht benutzen
hilfst du mir mit dem koffer
ist dein gepäck sehr schwer
ja der koffer ist nicht leicht
der pass die pässe
die ordnung
das flugzeug
im flughafen brauchst zudem passt
das ist in ordnung
ihr flugzeug fliegt 20 minuten später
der koffer die koffer
stellen
das gewicht
das gepäck
ist das ihr koffer
stellen sie ihn hier hin
das gewicht ist nur zehn kilogramm
wollen sie ihr gepäck mitnehmen
das ausland
der zoll
sie fliegen ins ausland
sie müssen noch durch den zoll
die müssen noch durch den zoll
weiter geht's im nächsten video
[Musik]